hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dudes stop a game that I
know absolutely nothing about so I'm not
even gonna try to explain it or relate
it to any other game that I played in
the past which I may or may not have
done but I'm gonna play it now so this
is made during the Ludum dare game the
game jam so oh I didn't read that hey I
gotta read the flavor text I forgot that
I did that already trying to get this
game to work there were bugs ah your
first time oh good you're here I just
hope you're not like all those other
players who like to touch drag or throw
around everything whatever let's play
which is what I tried to do at the
beginning of this game ha ha ha wait oh
I didn't actually now you broke the aim
happy oh no I can't exactly read what
you're saying I don't know what I'm
getting myself into but the rulebook
specifically says that you shouldn't do
that here I marked the page for you let
me look at that room ok I didn't even do
that just antagonize literally wind whoa
piece of candy ok anyway why you do you
do this here just look at this perfectly
straight painting and relax ok yeah yep
that is a straight painting yeah there
we go
did I Dunne's it ok and and another what
am I supposed to do about this huh I
can't beat your stupid game ah what do I
do seriously what do I do
what do I do
what am I supposed to do why do I do why
do I do I don't know what to do oh um
yes am I am i dumb am i dumb am I an
idiot
well obviously yes but am i stupid what
what did I do
I hate this game I hate it oh you're
really starting to get on my nerves
let's have a bathroom break and then
we're done uh-huh
okay so okay can i scrub haha oh I know
you don't
ha ha ha I hope you're not doing what I
think you're doing it's why am I in the
ladies room in the first place oh boy
hey I got the trophy I got a disgusting
horrible disease trophy for being a
monster good that's what you get you
stupid game oh boy I beat level pack
number one I'm the best baby oh man
you have disappointed everybody and this
is your reward you monster okay good
well what else do I get huh level pack
number two Oh something green and shiny
agree to go into the green light oh yeah
okay let's see what do we do dude stop
this mindless violence you don't need to
be that bad we can still save your soul
what am i doing this violent what
happens if I do this nothing to see how
look at me yeah I'm such a goody goody
gumdrops
oh I like Calibri hmm it's something all
right
it sure is ha
tip hahaha right in the spot I'm such a
nice guy
oh I did it
wait why is that one slightly red who
who bit makes me want to push it poink
everybody move it move it boy oh I have
a fit oh boy well hello there totally
average obedient person don't worry
you're doing fine I'm sorry
what so 50 points oh boy I'm doing so
good vote is that nice is that Donald
Trump is that Trump ah let's see
would you buy this game on Steam yeah
what did I get
oh boy I got a trophy a totally normal
person time to be a monster poink oh if
you wouldn't click that there would be
cake I'm not sure the cake is la haha
yeah references oh yeah okay how about
Comic Sans nobody mentioned undertale
it's coming don't worry there's
something happening with it it's just
slow going
I died a little bit inside oh boy how
about that good
she's the screams of agony don't need to
be so good I mean this is what I do
every day it's a fashion see Fashion
Police
okay never mind then this glowing red
one I actually don't sleep very well at
night that's actually something I'm very
tired I don't how do I make it not do
that no stop stop stop whoa geez
someone's a little angry over nothing
did you know that this is not a game
it's a test and you are a 99% monster
right what happened to the blunt force
oh oh okay
I think ask again later oh this game
wait what did I do
I don't know what I did
what did I did oh I thought now it's
gonna be bigger all right coming soon
agreed to go into the green light oh I
see I see what you're talking about
hey okay I did pretty good
I think that is okay I don't know how to
do the other one at the end of the game
or something oh there's so many emotions
playing that agony pissed off at Miss
other emotions that humans experience
whatever you humans I mean we humans may
do why did I do that
[ __ ] okay I am very tired but thank you
everybody so much for watching this game
I guess is over it may not be I may just
be stupid and not able to figure out how
to get to the rest of the game that's
all I've got for now so thank you so
much for watching and as always I will
see
in the next video Oh
every part of it I hate every stay in
line